Land und
[Musik]
prcht ja hallo Markus guten Abend wo
erreiche ich dich guten Abend Richard
der heuteute guten Abend ne und wo
erreichst Du mich ja ich binatsächlich
gerade in einem Hotel Z in kiefev und
sitze hier und höre dich so nah dass ich
das Gefühl habe du bist wirklich um die
Ecke bist du wo bist du gerade ja also
ich bin ja ja tatsächlich ein bisschen
entgegengereist ich bin in
Dresden okay genau ich habe morgen frü
eine Veranstaltung und bin in einem
Hotelzimmer in Dresden okay ja okay
verstehe genau und wie muss man sich das
vorstellen du bist in kieev im Hotel ja
es ist Abend es ist Abend wir warten auf
den mittlerweile schon fast gewohnten
nächtlichen Luftalarm und wenn das
passiert dann müssen wir jetzt auch
unterbrechen wir beide dann müssen wir
uns irgendwann heute Nacht um 2 Uhr
vielleicht noch mal verabreden es kann
wirklich alles passieren nichts ist
wirklich planbar und ja ansonsten äh
versuchen wir ein bisschen Ruhe jetzt zu
finden wir haben heute sehr viel
gearbeitet und sind hier auf einer
Reportagereise es ist wirklich eine
unglaublich spannende packende
berührende und ergreifende re mhm wir
haben ja schon so viel ne wir beide auch
über diesen Krieg gesprochen und ich
hatte speziell ist ja nicht entgangen
mich hat damals auch der Besuch in in
Moldawien aber dann auch in Odessa
insbesondere das ging mir damals
wirklich unter die Haut um ich hat das
eigentlich nie wieder wirklich
losgelassen und ich wollte immer noch
mal ein bisschen mehr wissen und
verstehen worum es hier eigentlich
wirklich geht und was hier passiert und
vor allen Dingen wie so ein
Krieg so eine Gesellschaft verändert und
das erleben wir hier gerade
deswegen reisen wir
gerade durch ganze Land haben in ganz im
Westen angefangen sind nach Krakau
geflogen und dann über diese berühmte
Autobahn rein über die alle reinfahren
und dann merkst Du sehr schnell in
welches Gebiet du da kommst wenn du dann
irgendwann kurz vor der Grenze nach
links schaust dann siehst Du plötzlich
so eine riesige eigentlich ist ist eine
Airbase ursprünglich mal so ein kleiner
Flughafen die ist jetzt zu einer
richtigen Airbase ausgebaut worden dann
startet da plötzlich so eine so so
riesiges amerikanisches
Transportflugzeug während du bei
McDonald's sitzt und dir einen einen
einen Burger zu Gemüte führst und du
merkst plötzlich ah okay alles klar hier
läuft die ganze Logistik hier kommt
richtig schweres Kriegsgerät rein hier
sind auch scholzum macron rein und so
weiter also jeder der im Moment sich auf
den Weg macht nach Kiev passiert
irgendwann mal diese große Autobahn und
ja und dann kommst du irgwann an diese
Grenze und es war dunkel und es war so
still und das war so
unheimlich aber nur ein Gefühl ne das
ist alles nur Emotion und ich ich darf
und will mich jetzt auch hier überhaupt
nicht dass der große ukraineexerte
aufspielen der bin ich nicht ich bin nur
ein neugieriger Reporter der durchs Land
fährt ja und ähm habe aber dennoch in
diesen Tagen jetzt Begegnungen gehabt
auch so mit den ganz einfachen Menschen
die mir wahnsinnig unter die Haut
gegangen sind weil es äh weil es
berührend war sehr offen war sehr
ehrlich war und vor allen Dingen
wahnsinnig freundlich war also was was
mich so so beeindruckt ist wie
freundlich nach wie vor dieses Land ist
äh du erlebst Menschen die im Stress
sind du erlebst Menschen die anderthalb
Jahre jetzt ausnahmituation leben und
die trotzdem immer ein Lächeln für dich
übrig haben die nett zu dir sind die
immer freundlich reagieren wenn sie
hören dass du aus Deutschland kommst die
sich bedanken für das was Deutschland
macht es hat mich wahnsinnig bewegt
da ist nichts abgebrühtes und so
forderndes und so weiter sondern die
bedanken sich und zwar ganz aufrichtig
und ehrlich jeder ob es ein
regierungsoffizieller ist ob es die Frau
ist die dir abends dann mal ein bisschen
Essen aufs Zimmer bringt oder so wenn du
dann spät nach Hause kommst der gestern
Abend war lud Miller hier im Zimmer die
ein bisschen englisch sprach und ich
sagte
Mensch schreib mal ein bisschen wie ist
in dein Leben so ja und und ich griff
dann so zu meinen Fritten und und sie
stand da so und hat dann erzählt eine
ganz einfache Frau und sagte weißt du
ich weiß was du denkst tagsüber sitzen
die Menschen hier im Kaffe und die
Geschäfte sind offen und die Sonne
scheint es ist wahnsinnig warm im Moment
hier 27 28° zum Teil und das Leben geht
weiter und dann sagte sie aber das ist
eine Illusion Markus das ist eine
Illusion weil nachts kommen die Raketen
und sie sprach es geradeaus und dann
ging draußen der Luftalarm los das kann
auch jetzt in jeder Sekunde passieren
dann müssen wir auch unterbrechen äh und
dann weißt Du okay jetzt sind irgendwie
wieder drei Raketen unterwegs und wir
hatten in der ersten Nacht direkt Alarm
von so onixraketen so heißen die die
Fliegen mit
884 m pro Sekunde also fast mach drei
kann dann bis zu 800 km weit fliegen und
das sind miese Geschosse Cruise Missiles
würde man sagen
die die Fliegen im Grunde wie ein
Flugzeug und die Fliegen ganz tief ganz
knapp überm Boden können bis zu 10 m
runtergehen also bis auf 10 m fliegen
dann an Flüssen entlang fliegen an
wäldtern entlang und so weiter und
keiner weiß genau wo das Ding
runterkommt und die wissen nur die
Dinger wurden gezündet die wurden
gestartet aber wo runter Zieleingabe wo
die einschlagen soll genau und die die
drei kamen dann in Odessa runter alle
drei weil gerade der Hafen dort massiv
attackiert wird h genau es hätte aber
auch
so dann dann hast du Bomben äh in einem
Dorf bei chason kam dieser Tage eine
Bombe runter halbe Tonne Sprengstoff
davon kamen vier Stück so da da da
fliegt allein durch die Druckwelle
fliegt alles durch die Luft da da machst
du gar nichts mehr und je näher du am
Kriegsgeschehen dran bist desto weniger
hast du eine Chance zu reagieren ja und
das das ist mies ja und das das ist das
was die Leute stresst ne das das ist das
was lut mer meinte ja du hast einfach du
und und das auch der Grund warum die
sagen weißt du wir wir können nicht mehr
und und wir gehen auch gar nicht mehr in
die Luftschutzräume sondern wir legen
uns auf den Flur
weil da müssen wir uns nicht irgendwie
zurecht machen weil sonst im
Luftschutzkeller triffst du wieder 1000
Leute und so weiter die Kinder musst du
wecken das willst Du alles nicht mehr
und dann legt man sich einfach in den
Flur irgendwo im Zentrum des Hauses dass
es einfach gut läuft genau weil die
regelimmer ist Versuch zwei Betonwände
zwischen dich und dem was draußen
passiert zu bringen und dann bete
einfach dass du keine schrabnell
abkriegst oder was auch immer du hast
gesagt der der Stress im Land ähm jetzt
hast du gerade beschrieben wie die
Situation in Kiev ist mM wie würdest du
das sagen als ihr in der Westukraine
wart ist das überall genau gleich also
das du sagen sozusagen ein gesamtes Land
in dieser latenten Unruhe dass man Angst
vor der Nacht hat oder würdest du sagen
das unterscheidet sich von Region zu
Region ziemlich
stark also wir haben jetzt nur sozusagen
die Erfahrung bis Kiev ja also wir sind
ja zunächst mal rein südlich von von
leviv früher Lemberg ein alte Habsburger
Stadt wunderschöne Stadt und sind da
rein und rein in die Karpaten und und da
sah ein bisschen aus ich habe mich sehr
an zu Hause erinnert gefühlt da gibt's
wunderschöne Berge da gibt's sehr
ländliches Leben da gibt's große
schaffferden da gibt's auch Bären da
gibt's Wölfe da gibt's alles und da
gibt's
auchebiete genau unser Lieblingsthema zu
bleben genau genau du würdest das mögen
wirklich ich unglaublich reizvoll ich
wusste nicht dass es Skigebiete in der
Ukraine gibt z.B und da gibt es dann so
Hotels da gibt's ziemlich gute
Infrastruktur und da machen dann
Soldaten Urlaub die entweder einfach nur
mal ein bisschen Zeit für sich brauchen
weil du den Wahnsinn nicht mehr
aushältst oder weil sie verletzt sind
und so weiter und dann läufst du da halt
alle paar Minuten irgendjemandem in die
Arme und unter anderem an dem Jungen
IT-Spezialisten den wir dort dann auch
befragt haben der war mit seiner Frau da
ganz junge Menschen unter 30 würde ich
sagen und
er er sagte dann auf die Frage ob das
eigentlich ein guter Moment ist für eine
Beziehung und dann meinte er ja auf
jeden Fall und wir haben jetzt ganz
bewusst die Entscheidung getroffen zu
heiraten haben wir jetzt gemacht mhm sag
ich okay wenn man verheiratet ist dann
hat man meistens auch die Absicht sich
zu vermehren ja Kinder zu kriegen mein
er ja wir üben gerade jede Nacht das
heißt mitten in diesen Krieg hinein wo
ich immer dachte nee jetzt ja gerade
nicht doch genau jetzt das war ja mein
selbst im Zweiten Weltkrieg nicht anders
ne genau genau und aber wenn du das dann
mal so da stehen diese zwei Menschen vor
dir sie hielt sie so ganz süßes süßes
Paar sie hielt sich immer so ein
bisschen an ihm fest und er versuchte so
erwachsen zu wirken aber du merktest er
ist so ein IT-Spezialist ich glaube der
arbeitet mit
rohnen ziemlich weit vorne an der
frontte die die die sind alle jederzeit
erreichbar ne durch russische Raketen
also sag mal bis 50 100 km kann da
jederzeit alles passieren und das wissen
die beiden auch ganz genau dass das
gefährlich ist und
ähm man fragt sich dann natürlich ne
stell dir vor das geht schief und das
wissen die auch dass das schief gehen
kann was ist das dann für eine Belastung
auch z.B für ein Kind das dann auf die
Welt kommt ja wenn wenn wenn ein Kind
dieser Tag ein sehr interessantes
Interview mit einer psycholog gelesen
hier aus der Ecke die sagte weißt du
wenn ein Kind zur Welt kommt und den
Mann gibt es nicht mehr den Vater gibt
es nicht mehr dann ist natürlich die
Gefahr wahnsinnig groß dass die Mutter
sozusagen diesen Jungen der es dann
möglicherweise ist einfach als Kopie
Ihres verlorenen Mannes gut auch hier ne
der Zweite Weltkrieg ist voll von
solchen Geschichten genau genau alle
Kriege dieser Welt sind voll von von
diesem richtig richtig was für ein was
für einen ja was für ein für einck sagt
nen du dann von Anfang an das ist wir
haben ja mal drüber gesprochen ne es ist
das Kriegsgeschehen ist das eine schlimm
genug genau und das andere sind die die
langen langen langen Folgen ne über zwei
drei Generationen h wegation genau die
Kriegstraumata die die Aggression
natürlich auch die die körperlichen
Verwundungen die die kulturellen
Schäden ganze Psychologie ja die 100
Jahre braucht um sich wieder zu
beruhigen die
Sozialpsychologie na also die ich glaube
das was ein ein Krieg anrichtet wir
diskutieren ja über diesen Krieg in
letzter Zeit unheimlich viel in rein
militärischen Begriff technisch sehr
technisch also es ist immer technischer
geworden also wenn ich mir die Debatten
angucke wo es darum geht die Rakete hat
die und die Reichweite und da ist jetzt
ein frontdurchbruch auf so und so viel
100 met gelungen und mit der Waffe
könnte man das noch und so also das
ganze hat so so ein sowas
computerspielartiges bekommen genau
was der der kriegsrealität die sich ja
im Augenblick abspielt überhaupt nicht
gerecht wird und du kriegst ja jetzt
zumindestens jetzt nicht direkt von der
Front aber von von von von dem wie die
Menschen sind mehr von der anderen Seite
des Krieges mit du du kriegst du kriegst
unheimlich viel mit du du siehst z.B
etwas was du bei uns gar nicht mehr
siehst ne Soldaten sind ein absolut
selbstverständlicher Teil eines
dorfbildes eines Stadtbildes an jeder
Ecke und überall und als ich mit den
beiden da gesprochen habe sagt der
Mensch hier ist doch so friedlich und so
schön schön und genießt dir das und sagt
auch er sagte zu mir weißt du täusch
dich mal nicht es gibt keinen einzigen
wirklich sicheren Platz in der gesamten
Ukraine es kann dich theoretisch überall
treffen es ist ein Spiel mit
Wahrscheinlichkeiten die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass es dich in der
Westukraine trifft ist deutlich kleiner
als in der Ostukraine aber es kann dich
jederzeit treffen und wir haben eine
junge Mutter ja die war vielleicht so 45
die Frau getroffen in in leviv
die war der Beleg dafür das war eine
Geschichte die hat mich hat mich völlig
umgehauen machte die Tür auf Natalja und
was ich sah waren drei Prothesen eine
Prothese an ihrem linken Bein und zwei
Prothesen an am an den Beinen ihrer
Tochter und die Geschichte dahinter ist
so so einfach wie wie grausam wie
tragisch sie geht mit ihren Zwillingen
Sohn und Tochter
äh in einen Bahnhof rein um die
Großmutter abzuholen der Junge bleibt
irgendwo zurück weil er keine Lust hatte
soweit mitzukommen und die beiden biegen
um die Ecke und dann macht's Krach und
als sie wach werden liegt die tote
Großmutter über diesem Mädchen die Beine
sind weg die Mutter wird wach und merkt
mir fehlt auch ein Bein und es beginnt
eine unglaubliche
Leidensgeschichte man wird erstmal
irgendwie notdürftig behandelt und dann
geht's weiter bis hin in die USA
prothesenspezialisten und so weiter am
Anfang wahnsinnige Schmerzen dann
gewöhnt man sich daran die machen die
Tür auf du siehst sie bewegen sich
einigermaßen normal und trotzdem ist es
so so erschüttern ein junges Mädchen das
sein Leben vor sich hat mit 12 Jahren
ganz hübsches süßes Kind ja die sitzt da
mit zwei Prothesen das wirklich das
zerreißt dir das Herz und dann erzählt
dir die Mutter sie hat nicht nur in dem
Zusammenhang ihre eigene Mutter verloren
bei ser bei dieser Attacke sie hat in
diesem Krieg bereits ihren Mann verloren
und ihren früheren Mann hat sie auch
verloren weil der ist an Krebs
verstorben das heißt diese Frau hatte in
kürzester Zeit so
unvorstellbar viel Hölle in ihrem Leben
so viel Tod in ihrem Leben dass du die
fragst wie hält ein Mensch das aus aber
Leben geht irgendwie weiter und ähm ich
ich ich habe dieser Tage so ein paar mal
da gesessen auch als wir da man fährt ja
dann sehr lange die Ukraine ist ein
riesiges Land und du siehst an der
niederecke werden Häuser gebaut es
werden Restaurant besucht es werden
Kinder gekriegt also weiterleben ist
quasi ein patriotischer Akt das ist es
weil wenn du das nicht tust das ist
jetzt ein steiles Wort weil ja aber
dieses weiterleben hat es ja immer und
in allen Kriegen gegeben ja es hat ja in
allen in allen Kriegen Alltag gegeben ja
und auch ich meine auch im im im Zweiten
Weltkrieg und es es gab Alltag in der in
der Zeit als die Alliierten die
deutschen Städte bombardiert haben ja
und zwar flächendeckend mit nach bei
jedem Bombenangriff 5 bis 10 000 Tote
oder ich bin jetzt gerade in Dresden der
größte alliierte Bombenangriff ja
überhaupt wo man dann noch neue Bomben
ausprobiert hat und die wurde sozusagen
diese Feuerhölle von Dresden inszeniert
hat und trotzdem hat es ja immer und zu
einen Zeiten mal ganz gleich ob jetzt
patriotischer Akt oder nicht ein
Weiterleben gegeben weil ich meine was
macht dir denn Hoffnung in so einer
Kriegssituation als das ganz bisschen
Glück des Alltags was du dann trotzdem
erfahren kannst und was Dir den deinem
Leben noch einen Wert le richtig richtig
ja genauso ist es weil du gerade Dresden
sagst ich wahrscheinlich weißt du das
Gerhard Baum ne das FDP Urgestein darf
man sagen bei einem Mann der schon über
90 Jahre alt ist und den ich sehr sehr
schätze liebe Grüße an der hat Baum
genau das ein oder andere Mal persönlich
erlebt und ja war gehörte zu den
wichtigen Begegnung der ist an der Hand
seiner Übergang russischen
Mutter aus dem brennenden Dresden gef FL
damals der hat das alles in den Knochen
deswegen ist der auch immer so klar wenn
es um diese um diese Frage geht und um
die Frage geht wie man sich zu verhalten
hat ja gegenüber einem einem Aggressor
wie Russland mm ja ja also es ist
ähm was das zweite was mir aufgefallen
ist das fand ich auch so interessant ne
wenn man wenn
man sein ganzes Leben lang sozusagen für
die Medien arbeitet äh dann kennt man
natürlich auch so bestimmte Mechanismen
und ich ich ich habe da was uns angeht
auch immer eine eine kritische Haltung
eine eine Skepsis ich es gibt ja ein
Dilemma dass du kaum auflösen kannst als
als Reporter oder als Journalist ja du
du gehst irgendwohin es passiert etwas
Schlimmes und alles stürzt sich drauf
wir wir standen dieser Tage vor einem
Wohnhaus in irpin das ist äh mit
Phosphorbomben irgendwie beworfen worden
dann kam noch Raketen hinterher und so
weiter glücklicherweise niemand ums
Leben gekommen das war in den
allerersten Kriegstagen weil die Leute
alle geflohen waren vorher aber übrig
geblieben ist eine fürchterliche Ruine
vor dieser Ruine waren nicht nur
hunderte Kamerateams und Journalisten
und Fotografen im Augen wahrscheinlich
meist fotografierte Ruine wel nee die
die die darauf wollte ich gerade hinaus
die Stufen die das so durchläuft dann
stürzen sich alle da drauf und jeder der
nicht wegrennt rechtzeitig wird befragt
und vor irgendwelche Kameras und so
weiter das klingt jetzt so
respektierlich so ist es gar nicht
gemeint es ist wichtig diese Geschichten
zu erzählen und und auf der anderen
Seite weißt du dass du jedes Mal den
Leuten auch etwas antust ja weil du
natürlich fragst wie war das und erzähl
doch mal und dann trigerst du wieder
dieses Trauma und diese fürchterlichen
Erlebnisse und das ist ein Dilemma das
kriegt man ganz ganz schwer aufgelöst
macron war vor diesem Haus Olaf Scholz
stand vor diesem Haus man kennt diese
Bilder wir standen da jetzt auch da war
jetzt jetzt keiner mehr nach anderthalb
Jahren ist sind sie alle verschwunden
und die Leute bleiben sozusagen alleine
zurück ja und ich habe gedacht wir
treffen da möglicherweise auf auf auf
echte Reflexe der der Abneigung dass die
Leute sagen komm geh mir weg ich ich
will von euch nichts mehr wissen das war
aber nicht so sondern du erlebst auch da
wieder diese sehr freundlichen Menschen
die als erstes bei der Arbeit sind die
packen unglaublich zu da ruft auch
keiner ich ich ich habe eine Frau die
vor ihrem komplett kaputt gebombten Haus
stand dass sie jetzt gerade mühsam
wieder aufbauen und die sagt auf die
Frage wer bezahlt das denn eigentlich
ich meine ich hab doch dieses Haus schon
mal bezahlt und es hat euch viel Geld
gekostet und ihr habt dann eine
wahnsinnige Mühe darauf verwendet euch
da irgendwie ein Leben einzurichten sie
sagt du was sollen wir denn machen wir
bauen das einfach selber wieder auf und
sag ich hilft euch der Start dann meinte
sie ja vielleicht da ein bisschen aber
wir verlassen uns da nicht drauf
her kan nicht in dem Sinne die Häuser
wieder aufbauen genau und sie ma die
Milliardenhilfen hören sich gewaltig an
aber wenn du das mal um rechnest auf das
was sozusagen an Einzelschicksalen und
was da tatsächlich passiert und was da
kaputt geht und so weiter abgesehen
davon dass das ja jetzt auch nicht
wahrscheinlich nach allen Regeln der
Kunst gründlich verteilt wird da macht
man sich bestimmt Illusionen ja ja und
dann dann merkst Du aber die Leute haben
ein großes bedürfn ist zu erzählen auch
wenn du Soldaten ansprichst im ersten
Moment kommt so ein so ein Abwehrreflex
ja weil darf nicht drüber reden ich habe
einen getroffen der kam gerade aus
bachmut zurück und er sagt ich ich ich
will nicht erzählen in keine Kameras und
sagt okay ist in Ordnung müssen wir
nicht und dann fing er an zu erzählen
und hörte nicht wieder auf also jenseits
der Kamera od ne dann auch vor der
Kamera sagte ne komm lass laufen ich
erzähle euch erstmal meine Geschichte
und das war das war wahnsinnig
beeindruckend und dann zeigt er dir
Bilder alles haben Sie auf Ihrem Handy
dokumentiert und so weiter das durft mir
dann natürlich nicht zeigen
aber da siehst du Sachen die kannst du
dir nicht vorstellen und man fragt sich
dann wie kriegt der das jemals wieder
aus seinem Kopf heraus ja gar nicht und
ja genau er sagt er sagt ich komme damit
gut zurecht du we er kommt damit gar
nicht zurecht ne die Leute die Leute
haben Ticks zum Teil die sind wahnsinnig
nervös die die die die die diesen
flackerigen Blick und so weiter denk ja
mal daran wie die vietnamkriegsveteranen
zurückgekommen sind als was und richtig
wir haben zweimal schon über den Film
weißer Raben geredet der vom
cheitchenienkrieg handelte diesmal von
russischen Soldaten ihre traumat nicht
los gewworden sind von denen einige
kriminell geworden sind andere später
Suizid begangen haben und so weiter ne
also das was was was die die
Gravur die da in dem Moment deine Seele
graviert ne die ritzt da was was ein was
du nie wieder in deinem Leben los wirst
genau ja genau
ja und so ist es halt ne wenn du durchs
Land fährst wir waren dann äh sind
rausgefahren nach nach
irpin butscha und da gab's eine
Situation du erinnerst dich vielleicht
wirklich ikonographische Bilder diese
Situation Brücke die die die die
Ukrainer selbst sprengen diese Brücke
über den Fluss damit die Russen nicht
weiterkommen mit ihren gepanzerten
Fahrzeugen und ihren Panzern und allem
was da reinrollte und
ähm es gibt dieses Bild wo dieser Soldat
dieser alten Frau irgendwie versucht
über diesen Fluss zu helfen ich weiß
nicht ob du dich dran erinnerst war
Winter war kalt war ein wirklich
herzzerreißendes Bild weil es klar
machte die ganze Verzweiflung und die
Not in der die Leute da plötzlich waren
plötzlich stehst du direkt vor dieser
Brücke und daneben rollt der Verkehr
vorbei und und Fahrräder fahren vorbei
und die Menschen leben einfach ihr Leben
ganz normal weiter aber du weißt das ist
eine weltberühmte Brücke Millionen von
Menschen haben diese Bilder gesehen äh
jeder verbindet mit diesen Bildern genau
das ja diese diese arme alte Frau die
versucht über diesen Fluss zu kommen und
dann stehst du da plötzlich und siehst
die versuchen das auch das wieder gerade
aufzubauen dann fuhren wir weiter kam an
so ein Parkplatz und ist ein ein wie
soll man sagen ein ein Art Autofriedhof
da haben sie diese ganzen Wracks aus
dieser berühmten Straße in in butscha
auch daran erinnert man sich ja diese
diese ganzen Autowracks und und und und
Wagen die da teils gepanzerte Fahrzeuge
ausgebrannt ja die da alle rumstanden
und rumlagen und die stehen da alle das
ist das ein ein ein ein ein absurder
Anblick ein ganz normale Straße so ein
so ein Highway und links ist ein
Parkplatz und plötzlich dieses
Trümmerfeld wenn du da jetzt hinkommst
ne also die das ganze hat ja eine
unglaubliche Tiefe bedeutungsfülle
Geschichte Symbolik mhm aber wenn du
dahinkommst und das siehst sieht es ja
wahrscheinlich vieles davon einfach nur
trivial aus genau so bedeutsam es ist
oder also du brauchst ja sozusagen
deinen Kopf ja um das was du siehst
wieder mit dem Leben zu füllen deswegen
ist mal berühmt oder besser gesagt
berüchtigt geworden ist ja ist wahr ja
du du stellst diesen Kontext her und
siehst gleichzeitig wie trivial das
alles ist butcha ist einfach ein Vorort
von von Kiev irpin ist einfach ein ganz
normaler Vorort von Kiev aber das wird
nie wieder für die die dort leben ein
normaler Vorort von Kiev sein und das
auch für das kulturelle Gedächtnis wenn
sich diese Namen einbrennen genau ja und
und und eine symbolische Bedeutung
behalten es kann sogar sein dass es für
die für die Kinder und für die für die
Enkel normale Orte werden aber es wird
für das kulturelle Gedächtnis werden es
keine normalen Orte ja das ist eben das
Thema und und da merkst du halt wo die
wirklichen Verwundungen dann auch sind
ne dann wird dir klar dass Krieg so
unendlich viel mehr ist als tote
Soldaten und kaputt geschossene Gebäude
zerstörte Gebäude zerstörte
Infrastruktur das da waren zwar kleine
Jungs 15 und 16 Jahre alt Mopet ja
fuhren da so ein bisschen rum
knnatterten durch die Gegend haben so
ein bisschen so auf halbstark gemacht
und so weiter und dann spreche ich die
an und frag sie woher sie kommen und der
eine sagt einen Namen den ich noch nie
gehört habe und der andere sagt butscha
und ich gucke ihn so an und er schaut
mich an ganz kurze Haare ganz
eindringlicher Blick schaut mich an und
sagt ja ja
Butscher und ich musste die Frage gar
nicht stellen dann fing der an diese
Geschichte zu
erzählen kriege ich jetzt noch Gänsehaut
er erzählte in allen Details wie er das
erlebt hat wie verzweifel die Situation
war wie sie sich im Keller
verbarrikadiert haben und wie sie sich
eingeredet haben wenn die jetzt zur Tür
reinkommen dann werden wir die alle
umbringen wir werden die wir werden die
besie wir lassen uns nicht von denen
umbringen und dann sage ich welche
Waffen hattet ihr denn der eine hatte
ein kleines Jagdgewehr und der Rest
hatte ein paar Messer das
war's so hofften die gegen bis an die
Zähne bewaffnete russische Mörder
irgendwie bestehen zu können hätten sie
natürlich niemals gekonnt sie hatten das
riesige Glück dass ihr Haus ein bisschen
am Wald dran steht deswegen kam die da
nicht dir vorbei aber dieser Junge hat
das alles gesehen ja ja klar hat diese
ST wir auch nie wieder vergessen undau
der hat diese ganzen Toten gesehen diese
Menschen gesehen die dort alle einfach
wirklich hingerichtet worden sind von
diesem Bestien man kann es wirklich
nicht anders sagen das ist eine ein ein
solcher
Gewaltexzess ja eine eine eine eine
solcher Abgrund eine Bereitschaft zu
Gewalt sowas kann man sich nicht
vorstellen und im Gesicht dieses jungen
siehst du das und du verstehst plötzlich
mit mit welcher Wucht das raau an diesem
Morgen und in den Tagen danach in das
Leben dieser Menschen eingebrochen ist
das verstehst du und der sagt dir dann
weißt Du ich werde den das nie verzeihen
ich werde das nie mehr vergessen und ich
werde alles tun um das irgendwann zu
rechen auch für Menschen die er gar
nicht kannte Menschen in seiner Umgebung
und das das die die ganz bittere poante
war ich ich habe die ganze Zeit seinen
kleinen Freund da beobachtet der stand
daneben und du konntest zusehen wie dem
die kindinlade runterfällt und
irgendwann sagt ich sag mal kennst du
diese Geschichte und sagt nein hat er
mir noch nie erzählt der hat das
allererste Mal darüber geredet so über
diese Geschichte geredet das allererste
Mal und auch da wieder ne dieser
Konflikt du du du hörst das denkst okay
geht geh da nicht so tief rein weil du
du traumatisierst den armen Jungen
wieder und deswegen ist es dann auch so
wichtig glaube ich einfach nur ein
Gefühl aber ihn hinterher wieder auf
zufangen wir haben hinterher gescherzt
und über Motorräder geredet und so
weiter um sozusagen wieder
zurückzukehren ins normale Leben aber
ich hatte in dem Moment das Gefühl er
wollte das Erzählen und er hat es auch
erzählt und das war unglaublich bewegend
MMM und den habt ihr mit seinem Freund
da quasi zufällig auf der Straße Anges
ja genau und das ist das ist halt die
die die die Lektion die du ganz schnell
hier lernst du du triffst Menschen es
ist egal wen frag irgendjemanden und du
kommst ganz schnell in ein nettes
Gespräch weil weil die Leute so sind
gerade jüngere Leute sprechen teilweise
excellent Englisch sind sind Leute wir
haben an auf einer Hochzeit wir bekamen
morgens das war der allererste Drehtag
die der allererste Moment wir standen D
noch an der Rezeption rum wollten uns
fertig Maen für den Dreh und plötzlich
kommt so eine Hochzeitsgesellschaft auf
uns zu und ich ich schau mir dies so
Moment an und dann werden Fotos gemacht
und Dach ne weißt du was jetzt ich muss
die jetzt mal fragen und dann begann
diese Geschichte und plötzlich waren wir
mittendrin und waren im Gespräch mit
hier dieser junge Leute die da auf
dieser Hochzeit eingeladen waren und
fragt die wie das ist und ob das was das
mit ihnen macht dieser Krieg und wie es
ist eine Hochzeit zu feiern in in einer
solchen Situation die sagten hey das
Leben geht weiter wir haben aber den
Blick die Perspektive auf das Leben
vollkommen verändert sagte so eine
blonde junge Frau sagte weißt du ich
habe gelernt man muss mal ein Risiko in
Kauf nehmen und wir leben alle jetzt ein
bisschen schneller aber wir leben und
wir machen weiter und jetzt erst recht
dieser dieser dieser diese Resilienz
dieser
Durchhaltewille das das beeindruckt ein
muss ich wirklich sagen und man fragt
sich immer könnte man das selber auch
und und ich ich glaube wir könnten das
auch ich glaube Menschen sind so ich
glaube in so existenziellen Situationen
schon nach all dem was du erzählt hast
was ist das stärkere Gefühl oder die
stärkere Einsicht in dir auf der einen
Seite zu sagen das Unrecht das hier
geschehen ist mm das darf nicht
durchgehen die Ukraine mit Kost es was
es wolle und sein es noch viele Jahre
Krieg ihre Gebiete zurück erobern um das
dem der russischen Aggression nicht
durchgehen zu lassen mhm oder sagst du
jeder Tag der kein Frieden ist und dem
dieser mörderische Krieg weitergeht ist
ein Verbrechen an den Menschen die an
ihm beteiligt sind welches ist das
dominierendere Gefühl wenn Du diese
Gespräche geführt hast und durchs Land
gefahren bist tatsächlich ist es weder
das eine noch das andere die die
natürlich hört man das immer so als
durchhalte pararole wir werden erstens
diesenkrieg gewinnen wir werden alle
Gebiete befreien aber das glaubt ganz im
Ernst glaube ich keiner aber das Inter
habmer den Eindruck in manchen deutschen
Talkshows wird das geglaubt dass am Ende
alle Gebiete befreit werden können na ja
es gibt zumindestens Menschen die das
sagen also Norbert rötken oder Frau
stckzimmermann oder so die sagen es ist
einfach nur eine Frage der
Waffentechnologie und wie viel der
Westen bereit ist zu investieren so habe
ich das bisher jedenfalls immer
verstanden ja ich ich verstehe das immer
als eine taktische Äußerung weil ich
einfach denke okay es ist klar wenn man
eine gute Position für Verhandlungen
irgendwann mal haben will wenn beide
Seiten soweit sind dass sie schlicht und
ergreifen nicht mehr können dann geht's
natürlich darum den Preis hochzutreiben
also ich glaube schon dass da taktische
erwgungen sowohl bei Norbert rötk als
auch bei Marie AGN stagzimmermann eine
Rolle spielen
ähm das das oder auch bei ruderich
Kiesewetter beispielsweise ja oder
Masala aber ja aber was was tatsächlich
das Thema ist ist ein anderes die Leute
fragen dich sofort zurück die sagen wenn
du sie fragst sag mal sollte man jetzt
nicht jetzt Sara Wagenknecht Argument
sollte man nicht alles tun um
Verhandlungen richtig zu pushen dann die
Lachen nicht aus die die sagen wie denn
wie sollen wir das denn machen da ist
auf der anderen Seite eine Grausamkeit
die könnt ihr euch nicht vorstellen
diese Leute aber aber auch eine
Perspektive dass die Russen ja den den
Krieg als Krieg auch nicht gewinnen
können also ich glaube das steht ja
genauso fest also ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass der russische
Generalstab davon
ausgeht dass sie auf militärischem
Wege was denn auch also mir ist bis
heute übrigens nicht klar was das
Kriegsziel ist ne also das ist eine
Frage über die wir ja relativ selten
reden also auf der einen Seite
steht die These im Raum das Kriegs sei
die Eroberung der gesamten Ukraine
dagegen steht die andere Vorstellung es
geht um die Eroberung von donjk luhansk
und den südgebieten die man jetzt hat
genau auch das ist ja eigentlich nicht
wirklich klar also es herscht ja noch
nicht mal eine Klarheit über das
russische Kriegsziel und deswegen ist ja
auch ziemlich unklar wenn man anfängt
darüber zu verhandeln was denn die
russische Seite überhaupt was deren
Forderungen letztendlich sind ist sind
ist das völlig klar also was glaubst Du
ist das realistische russische
Kriegsziel zum gegenwärtigen Augenblick
also ich ich kann das in keinster Weise
beurteilen die reden ja auch nicht mit
mir ja und schon gar nicht mit mir aber
übrigens mit Norbert rötkin und Marie
Agnes STR ja das wissen die ja auch
nicht aber die genau die die die der
Punkt ist natürlich die Leute hier haben
wirklich Angst und die sagen weißt du
wenn wenn wenn die Russen mit dem Krieg
aufhören hört der Krieg auf aber wenn
wir aufhören dann hört die Ukraine auf
das ist so ein so ein Schlagwort auch
geworden ne das hört man ja auch
teilweise in Deutschland genau diesen
Satz dieses Argument aber natürlich ist
an dem Argument wirklich was dran und
die haben wahnsinnige Angst dass das
wieder von vorne losgeht dieser dieser
dieser ganze Terror ich habe heute mit
einer jungen Fotografin gesprochen
äh ähm Soja Schu die ein berühmtes Foto
gemacht hat ähm und zwar ein Foto aus
einem Folterkeller an an in Russland und
du siehst den Rücken eines ukrainischen
Soldaten und darauf ein Hakenkreuz
geritzt und du denkst es ist ein Foto
aus diesem Krieg dieses Foto ist 2014
entstanden diese ganze Geschichte
beginnt 2014 und das haben die Ukrainer
unglaublich präsent wir wollten das
damals nicht hören ich habe dieser Tage
glaub die Geschichte beginnt noch lange
vor 2014 ja wahrscheinlich auch das aber
sozusagen als Krieg wirklich für die
Leute wahrnehmbar war es das und ich
habe heute die
ehemalige vizeregierungschefin gehört
die sagte hier in in Kiev die sagte auch
wir haben es unser eigenen Bevölkerung
zu bequem gemacht das war die
Formulierung die sie benutzt hat wir
haben wir haben nämlich die Leute
glauben lassen da gibt es irgendwo da
hinten weit im Osten da im donbas kurz
vor der russischen Grenze da gibt's so
ein bisschen Konflikt und D ein bisschen
Theater und so weiter aber eigentlich
lebt euer Leben weiter und genau genauso
haben sie es auch gemacht sagt aber
diese Fotografin sagt heute schon da
konnte man sehen wie es immer härter und
immer härter und immer grausamer wurde
wie unvorstellbar brutal gefoltert wurde
in diesen besetzten Gebieten und heute
sagt sie und das jemand der sich da
wirklich auskennt weil sie ganz tief
drin ist in diesen Projekten auf eine
Art und Weise die kannst du dir nicht
vorstellen sie erzählte von einem Mann
der in russische Gefangenschaft geraten
der hat
äh den den den Fehler gemacht irgendwo
bei bei bei Facebook irgendwas zu posten
was den nicht passte äh irgendwas über
positives über die Ukraine geschrieben
dann haben die den geholt haben ihn
einen Keller reingepackt haben ihn dann
nach Russland verschleppt der ist fünfm
an ganz verschiedene Orte versteppt
worden war hunderte hunderte von Tagen
in
Isolationshaft 40 kg Gewicht verloren
diese Leute werden systematisch
geschlagen jeden einzelnen Tag der hat
in seiner Verzweiflung irgendwann Ratten
gegessen hat Würmer gegessen und wenn er
mal raus durfte hat er hat er erzählt
dass er dass er ging er so mit der Hand
einmal üers Gras um einmal den Duft von
Gras zu riechen der ist davon
ausgegangen dass er nie wieder
zurückkommt der ist in in dieser
Gefangenschaft ich GLB um um um 7 oder 8
cm geschrumpft weil sie ihn so
verprügelt haben und arbeitet jetzt
wieder als LKW-Fahrer und sagt ich will
dass die Welt dieses Bild sieht
und ich will dass die Leute diese
Geschichte hören und das ist das ist
keine Ausnahme ne das ist Alltag
systematische Folter in diesen
russischen Folterkellern und das ist das
ist das wovor die Menschen hier Angst
haben und deswegen sagen Leute das habe
ich nicht verstanden also wenn der Krieg
eingefroren wird dann ist doch die
Hoffnung dass das zu Ende geht nee dann
ist doch nicht dann ist doch sozusagen
dann ist doch diese unmittelbare
Bedrohung geringer und nicht größer nee
das glauben das glauben die den eben
nicht die Ukrainer sagen die hier ich
ich kann nur wiedergeben Richard ne ich
bitte ich beziehe da keine Position ja
ich kann nur wiedergeben und ich ich ich
ich ich sehe auch natürlich ne wie hier
die Propaganda läuft wie unvorstellbar
viele Plakate zu sehen sind wie wenn du
mit der Bahn fährst von von lewiv nach
Kiev beispielsweise dann hast du die
Monitore ja wo dann irgendwelches
Fernsehen läuft und dazwischen ein Clip
nach dem anderen der sozusagen dieses
diese diese heroisierenden Kriegsbilder
zeigt und so weiter also man kann das
alles sehr skeptisch sehen aber was die
Ukrainer dir selber sagen ist welche
Wahl haben wir wir wir werden attackiert
und die machen weiter die kommen wieder
die sind schon zweimal jetzt gekommen
die kommen auch ein drittes Mal aber ist
das nicht eine Mitverantwortung ist das
nicht eine
Mitverantwortung die wir tragen dass wir
zu einem Frieden beitragen die dafür der
dafür sorgt dass sie nicht ein drittes
Mal kommen ich meine sie kommen ja nicht
ja so grausig der Krieg ist ja aber sie
kommen ja aus ihrer Position gesehen aus
rationalen Motiven ne wir finden die
verbrecherisch die sind
völkerrechtswidrig und so weiter aber
die Position der Russen ist die Nato hat
sich immer weiter an unsere hausti
ausgedehnt den des drohen Atomraketen es
droht nateitritt der Ukraine und so
weiter wenn wir über diese Dinge
verhandeln würden hältst du das für
völlig ausgeschlossen dass man
verhindert dass dieser Krieg und sei
nach einem kurzen waffenstüstand als
dritter oder vierter Krieg dass dieser
Konflikt nicht beendet werden kann
hältst du das für undenkbar den Konflikt
zu beenden so wie es offensichtlich
undenkbar ist den Konflikt zwischen
Palästinensern und Israelis zu wenden
hältst du das wirklich für völlig
unmöglich glaubst du nicht dass de eine
Lösung gefunden werden kann wenn auch
nicht eine Lösung die innerhalb der
nächsten Woche im parat liegt aber ich
meine auch sowas wächst sich ja so
grausig das ist was du da gerade erlebst
und beschreibst über die Generationen
auch irgendwann raus ja wobei wenn du
die Leute fragst was glaubt die wie
lange das geht dann sagen wir dir das
geht noch Jahre Jahre aber das kann
wahrscheinlich gar nicht Jahre gehen
oder doch die die geht die Ukrainer
brauchen 3 bis 400 000 Mann jedes Jahr
ja aber wie wie wie viel wie
viele werfähige Männer werden denn in
der Ukraine also Männer zwischen 18 und
wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt 60
sondern 40 oder so die man als Soldaten
richtig einsetzen kann
oder ja glaubst du dass dass die Ukraine
diese diese das gesamte Potential dieser
Menschen sterben lässt die Frage die
Frage habe ich den auch gestellt und die
Frage stellen die sich nicht weil soweit
denken die nicht das verstehst Du auch
ganz schnell wenn du hier bist es gibt
heute und dann gibt's noch Morgen und
vielleicht noch übermorgen was dann ist
werden wir irgendwann mal sehen aber
erstmal geht's darum durchzukommen
irgendwie zu überben dieses Morgen und
das übermorgen keine ernstzunehmenden
Erfolge zeitigt muss man doch an die
langfristigen Dinge denken oder nicht
ich meine es doch auch in der Ukraine
intellektuelle geben die sich darüber
Gedanken machen oder ja ja ja ja die
gibt es aber tatsächlich sind sie nicht
laut das ist sehr interessant und tust
dich schwer sozusagen die die kritische
Stimme zu finden die sagt jetzt jetzt
müssen wir hier damit mal aufhören
sonder und und das hat gar nichts mit
Politik zu tun die sehen ihren eigenen
Präsidenten zum Teil sehr kritisch und
so weiter die die sehen auch darüber
gibt z.B auch eine Debatte ne also das
im im im im im Fernsehen wird
unglaublich viel pro selenski berichtet
und so weiter und die ganze Nacht geht
das ganze Thema da läuft einfach richtig
die die Kriegsmaschinerie was ja auch
normal ist kriegen Kri genau aber aber
darüber gibt's Diskussion Leute sagen
das das das kann man doch so nicht
machen aber es ist halt der der weißt du
die Motivation der Russen die das
übrigens wenn du die Demografie anguckst
130 Millionen ne versus die Ukraine hat
mittlerweile 6 Millionen Menschen
verloren die die sind die sind die sind
weg die sind zum Teil gestorben die sind
zum Teil weg
also das Kriegsziel hat Putin schon mal
erreicht die aber ist der kriegsverlau
damit nicht programmiert ja das ist eben
das ist eben die ganz große
entscheidende Frage aber die sehen halt
und ich ich habe heute mit einem mit
einem Mann gesprochen der war ich ein
Kollege von dir der war Autor vor dem
Krieg und der organisiert jetzt für das
Verteidigungsministerium die Rückkehr
von
Kriegsgefangenen was der dir erzählt
macht dir irgendwann mal klar was er
meint wenn er sagt Russland das ist eine
Kultur des Todes und das war es
historisch immer schon sagt er es der
der das Leben hat keinen Wert und sich
für den Zaren und jetzt für den neuen
Zaren zu opfern das ist eine heroische
Sache und da stellt keiner große Fragen
ich glaube dass das viele junge Menschen
in Russland ganz anders sind in den
Städten in den großen Städten R
natürlich Pet auf dem Lande die auf dem
Lande hatten in ihrer ganzen Geschichte
nie irgendeine W richtig richtig und und
das sind genau diese Leute das verstehst
du auch hier auch übrigens in der in der
in der Ukraine ne das sind das sind
natürlich Leute wir ein Mann getroffen
das halbe Gesicht
weggeschossen der Körper über und über
übersätt von Narben und so weiter der
geht zieht jetzt in zwei Tagen wieder in
den Krieg hat irgendwie versucht mit dem
wirklich mit dem Rest seines Gesichts
eine Zigarette zu rauchen und sagt ich
ich muss das jetzt hier machen das sind
natürlich einfache Menschen ja das ist
nicht der der erfolgreiche Anwalt der da
vor dir steht das ist schon klar aber
bei den Russen das erzählt dir eben auch
ähm Petr so hieser der Mann aus dem
Verteidigungsministerium der sagte das
sind das sind Leute da triffst du
40jährige die sehen aus wie 60 70 die
sind in ganz erbärmlichen Zuständen
kommen die hier an die haben mieses
Material die sind gesundheitlich
überhaupt nicht auf der Höhe viele von
denen kommen direkt aus dem Gefängnis
viele von denen haben haben sind HIV
positiv und auch kurz davor dann an Aids
zu erkranken viele haben Tuberkulose
viele haben beides aber ist do klar ich
meine jetzt im Ernst wer will schon in
so einen Krieg geschickt werden na ja
genau ja dass dass du das zum Teil mit
dem letzten Aufgebot zu tun hast richtig
dass du es mit Menschen zu tun hast die
nichts zu verlieren haben dass du es
auch noch mit einer gewissen Portion an
Sadisten zu tun hast genau das der Punkt
ja ich meine das das alles ist Krieg
genau ich stell mir ganz ehrlich gesagt
einen Krieg den Krieg im Jemen nicht
anders vor was sind das für Leute die da
Warlords sind was sind das für Leute die
da Dörfer aushungern und so weiter ne
also das das gleiche gilt für für die
anderen afrikanischen Kriege von denen
ich weiß und ich weiß auch welche
irrsinnigen verrohungen der Krieg mit
dem ich groß geworden bin ist ja
Vietnamkrieg ne weil meine Eltern sich
da interessiert ist ja nicht der
richtige
ausdruckier engagiert natürlich und ja
zwei adoptivgeschwister aus dem
Vietnamkrieg hab und so weiter ich habe
schon schon in sehr jungen Jahren diese
Bilder gesehen von diesen kzen
Kriegsversehrten Kindern also zum Teil
wenn Sie hier waren aber eben auch die
Fotos und von napimopfern und all diesen
Sachen Krieg treibt die die
schrecklichsten Dinge hervor und zieht
die schrecklichsten Menschen an das ist
das ist glaube ich so grausig das klingt
normal für Kriege und deswegen kennst du
ja auch meine Position dass ich immer
denke jeder jeder weitere Kriegstag ist
ein ein verlorener Tag für alle Menschen
auf beiden Seiten
aber der Unterschied zwischen uns beiden
ist ich habe nicht mit den Menschen
gesprochen mit denen du gesprochen hast
und sag mal wohin wollt ihr weiter gehen
was habt ihr auf dem Programm was wollt
ihr euch ansehen mit wem wollt ihr noch
sprechen wir wir werden jetzt morgen
unsere Fahrt fortsetzen werden jetzt
weiter runter Richtung Süden werden nach
mikolajev werden dann in die Region um
Cherson wissen jetzt aber noch nicht so
ganz genau wie nah wir daran kommen das
da gibt's einen Fluss und der ist
sozusagen der Frontverlauf also mit in
der Stadt auf der einen Seite die Russen
auf der anderen Seite die Ukraine und du
erinnerst dich vielleicht an die Bilder
da gab's ja diese diese diese diese
Jubelbilder von der Befreiung das haben
die Ukrainer im zurück erobert ja und
mittlerweile und speziell in den letzten
drei Tagen
tobt da wieder richtig also
Dauerbeschuss wirklich und jetzt müssen
wir mal sehen ob wir diesen Plan
tatsächlich aufrech erhalten können gibt
ja auch die Dörfer drumherum wo du
wirklich diese diese wirklich diese
Politik der verbrannten Erde siehst so
wie es die Nazis damals in in
Skandinavien gemacht haben einfach
brandschatzen durch die Gegend und einf
mal alles kaputt schlagen was da steht
und dann gucken wir wie weiter das ist
und das ist halt das was was was
was einem so nahe geht wenn man das so
sieht und die Ukrainer das ist auch
interessant ich habe unterschätzt jetzt
bin ich natürlich auch unter dem
Eindruck von von leevv das auch eine
sehr quirlige fröhliche schöne Stadt
auch unter dem Eindruck von Kiev auch
eine
eine wirklich interessante Stadt moderne
Stadt die sind so westlich die sind so
nah bei uns aber du warst in der Tat
jetzt quasi überwingt in den Gebieten
die auch historisch historisch mal zu
Österreich Ungarn Gehör gen und sieht
man ich glaub es ist eine ganz andere
Welt in die Welt zu kommen die über
Jahrhunderte in russisch war richtig
richtig das das ist der Punkt aber man
sieht dennoch sozusagen diese diese
diese was du immer wieder hörst ist wir
wollen einfach in Freiheit leben und es
gibt einen riesigen Unterschied und ich
habe muss wirklich zugeben ich habe das
unterschätzt ich habe auch als das
losging gab's ja oft bei uns auch die
Debatte ja sind ja so Bruder Länder und
Völker und so weiter und eigentlich sind
sozusagen die die Ukraine einfach nur
andere Russen das ist falsch das ist
wirklich absolut falsch
und wie unterscheidest du das ich ich
also das sagen die die ersten selbst und
sie sagen es vor allen Dingen mit Blick
auf die Entwicklung in den letzten 10
Jahren Maidan ist so ein ganz markanter
Punkt aber auch schon die Jahre davor da
hat echt etwas stattgefunden und da
gibt's das ist eine andere Art sozusagen
das Leben zu begreifen und wenn du hier
in Kiev so ein jungen Studenten triffst
oder diese itila z.B der unterscheidet
sich nichts von einem itiler den du in
London triffst oder New York triffst
oder in Singapur triffst auch nicht von
einem den N in Moskau oder in Minsk
triffst oder ja ja aber ich muss nicht
ist das nicht eher sozusagen die die
Zugehörigkeit zu einer zur globalen
Kaste der anywares zu denen die dazu
gehören nicht der somewares ja diese
berühmte Unterscheidung also und das
kann ich mir sofort vorstellen diese
Leute sind absolut international und sie
arbeiten ja auch im Berufen indem sie
international einsetzbar ist mich würde
einfach die die Perspektive eines eines
Bauern in donj interessieren ja genau
die die werden wir auch no genau die
werden wir auch noch hören da bin ich
sehr gespannt darauf auch im Süden wie
die Leute das sehen wenn man so auf die
Dörfer
rausgeht aber was für mich tatsächlich
ein markanter Unterschied ist wir haben
2018 mal längere Zeit in Russland
gedreht und mich hat dieses Land damals
weißt du ja sehr sehr berührt die
Menschen berühren dich aber die Art und
Weise wie sie sprechen hat mich damals
wahnsinnig an Kuba erinner
in Kuba führst du auch solche Gespräche
in Kuba redest du mit Menschen und sie
benutzen Codes sie sagen dir durch die
Blume Dinge die sie eigentlich ger nicht
loswerden würden aber sie sagen sie
nicht wirklich offen weil sie genau
wissen was ihn im zweifelisft Rot und
ich erinnere mich an das Gespräch thamas
in Kuba mit einem Priester und und
solche Gespräche kannst du auch in
Russland auf der Straße führen schon
2018 konnte man die führen und ich ich
habe den damals gefragt warst du mal im
Gefängnis weil du relativ deutlich deine
Meinung sagst und er sagte zu mir nur
glaub mir Markus es gibt viele Arten von
Gefängnis und er war wirklich im
Gefängnis auch mehrfach und der war aber
auch in seiner ganz eigenen Hölle in
seinem ganz eigenen Gefängnis weil er
eben nicht sagen durfte was er wollte
und dieses Gefühl hatte man damals in
Moskau auf der Straße schon massiv
dieses Gefühl hatte man sogar im sehr
liberalen stankt petersburg und auf dem
Land sowieso und der der Unterschied den
Leute auch wie wie äh Petro z.B den ich
heute getroffen habe machen der auch
historisch sehr beschlagen ist der sagt
weißt du Russland das ist ein ein ein
Machtapparat der sein Volk immer immer
unterdrückt hat richtig und die üben
diese Macht aus und diese Macht Ausübung
von oben nach unten so hat das auch
ausgedrückt diese diese vertikale macht
die führt dazu dass du unten irgendwann
eine also eine dunkle Energie hast die
sich irgendwann wenn sie kann auf
brutalste Art und Weise bahnbricht nicht
genau entlet und das ist wirklich der
große Unterschied wenn du wenn du in in
der Ukraine hier mit mit Leuten sprichst
zumindest an den Ort in den wir waren
jeder redet offen niemand denkt darüber
nach was der Staat die Polizei der
Geheimdienst möglicherweise denken oder
mitkriegen könnte von dem was du sagst
es spielt überhaupt keine Rolle und das
merkst Du sofort am Verhalten der Leute
s das ist der große
Unterschied ja bin jetzt sehr gespannt
ein bisschen ein mulmiges Gefühl ich
weiß als wir als wir aus aus aus lebiv
und da von den Karpaten von diesen
schönen Karpaten hier hier rüber sind
sagten dann auch unsere unsere Jungs
hier wir haben ein paar sehr gute
Sicherheitsleute um uns herum die die da
noch die die Quellen haben die man
braucht wenn man verstehen will was da
jetzt gerade so passiert und woher
möglicherweise die Rakete kommt oder ob
der Luftalarm nur deswegen ausgelöst
wurde weil beispielsweise auf russischem
Territorium drei Jets gestartet sind und
keiner weiß so genau wo die hinfliegen
ja solche Dinge passieren hier halt auch
ständig nicht äh und die sagten als wir
in Kiev angekommen sind so ab jetzt ist
hier eine andere Welt macht euch das
klar und ich weiß genau was die morgen
abend sagen werden die werden morgen
Abend die mikolajev sagen und jetzt ist
noch mal eine ganz andere Welt
hier das ist so und ich hoffe dass wir
da gut durchkommen und dann werden wir
irgendwann über Odessa diese
wunderschöne Stadt die wir schon im März
besucht haben da wieder rausgehen und
m bin auch gespannt wie sich Odessa
jetzt verändert hat ist auch gerade
massiv unter
Beschuss genau genau der werden Odessa
ist ja musst du verstehen ne Odessa ist
so unendlich wichtig allein der Zoll in
Odessa für die Wirtschaft der der
Ukraine ganz ganz ganz entscheidender
Faktor die ich glaube allein der der
also der Zoll ist eine der wichtigsten
Einnahmequellen in der Ukraine ja und
nur damit du man eine Zahl hast die
finde ich so beeindruckend von Januar
bis August hat allein der Zoll 7,8 also
fast 8 Milliarden Dollar an den
Finanzministern Kiev abgeliefert und das
ist ungefähr so viel wie die
steuerannahmen sonst im gesamten Land
also die Hälfte praktisch ja und fast
alles von diesem Zoll wird inesser
erarbeitet genau Schiffe mit Getreide
die dort abfahren die Weltmärkte dann
versorgen und so weiter Lastwagen
eisenbahntransporte nach Moldau Rumänien
und so weiter das heißt wenn das wenn
das gelingt diesen ha und wirklich äh
kaputt zu bomben kaputt zu bomben genau
dann wird's immer schwieriger genau ja
dann bleibt mir nicht viel mehr Markus
als ja eine gruhame Nacht zu wünschen
und in diesem Fall ist es keine Floskel
äh ich weiß das genau und allein das ne
ist so eine Selbstverständlichkeit bei
dir jetzt gerade in Dresden für uns
jetzt aber hier nicht also es kann in
jeder Sekunde kannst losgehen dann warnt
dich die App wieder dann geht's in
diesen in diesen in diesen Raum der da
irgendwie da sind Matratzen ausgelegt
und so weiter und dann wartet man ab es
kann Stunden gehen und mir sagte diese
eine junge Frau auf der Hochzeit weißt
du man gewöhnt sich an alles wir haben
gelernt damit umzugehen und so ist es
jetzt mittlerweile so wie übernachten
einfach manchmal im Luftschutzkeller
dann schminke ich mich halt da und dann
gehe ich einfach von da zur Arbeit das
fand ich fand ich irgendwie beklemmend
aber irgendwie auch wahnsinnig
schön optimistisch ist weißt du weil
genau und weil es weil es zeigt was was
Menschen so können und die andere Frau
sagte mir als sie vor ihrem total
kaputten Haus stand sagte sie weißt du
es ist egal ob der Staat mir hilft oder
nicht ich habe zwei Arme ich habe zwei
Beine wir ziehen das hier durch und das
muss wieder aufgebaut werden ja genau
und so machen wir das auch hier also
insofern ich werde dir viel erzählen
Richert wenn ich wieder zurück
bin auch du eine gute Nacht und freue
mich auf Dich bis dann ja bis dann
tschüss
Ciao eine Produktion von mh2 und
podstars bei OMR im Auftrag des
[Musik]
ZDF